so for this we're going to talk about investing
personal finance and because i get asked
on all my social all the time can you give me some
advice what can i do with my money how can i make
more money for my money um so the first thing i
want people to understand is basically i talk a
lot in my videos about how wealthy people make
a lot of money from their money so if you have
like £10million which a lot of wealthyfamilies
do then they might make £300,000a year
just from their money it's important to
understand that they're able to make that money
because they are so super rich so it's pretty
ordinary for wealthy people wealthy families
to make sort of 3-5% fromtheir money
that's where i get these numbers from
so then if you have a family wealth of £10million
you can make £300,000- £500,000
um and that's easy enoughto live a
good life off but for ordinary people
who might have £10,000 - £20,000 if you
make3% you know it's better than not
making it but it's not gonna change your life
right if you have £20,000 savings
and you make 3% that's going tomake
you £600 a year right which isgreat
you want to make it £600 a yearbut
it's not going to change your life so
i have a bit of a concern that sometimes people
come to me asking for advice and often what they
really want is kind of get rich quick schemes
you know we've seen a lot of people make a lot
of money very quickly on things like bitcoin and
things like this in recent times um or tesla these
sort of things have gone up super quickly and
um i think often when people ask for this kind
of advice that's what they're looking for you
know they're looking to like make you know huge
amounts of money despite only starting with
10 20 £30,000 i think it's important for people
to realize the reason that super rich people and
very rich people are able to make huge amounts of
money from their money is because they start with
huge amounts of money so these guys who already
have even £1million, £2million that
can makeyou like £50,000 £100,000
a year to live off but for ordinary people
who might have savings of 20 30 £40,000
you're not going to make lifechanging
sums and people who do offer you sort
of get rich quick schemes invest 20 30
£40,000you're gonna make a £100,000
please be very very skeptical of thoseguys
they're probably not people you can trust um
realistically what we're talking about is ifyou
can make 10% 20% from your money then you're
doing really really really well but even that if
you make 20% which is a really super good return
and you start with £50,000 that's making you
£10,000 a year so it's obviously it's great
money but that's a fantastic return and it's
um you know it's not going to change your life
so that's the first thing um when we talk
about investing you need to understand that
it's not going to make huge amounts of money
unless you start with huge amounts of money
and that's an important point because i often
think people come to me from ordinary backgrounds
even maybe poor backgrounds like where i'm
from and they see investing as a way out of
out of poverty out of a difficult situation but
the truth is the way things are set up right now
it's not a reliable way out and um everything
you do every way you try to make money by for
example you know betting on bitcoin or um betting
on the stock market is risky you can lose money
basically it's not a reliable way out and
the reason why i talk about what i talk about
saying we need to bring in a wealth tax is
because these kinds of solutions encouraging
ordinary people to gamble on the stock market
to gamble on cryptocurrencies i think they're
super dangerous basically and they're not
reliable ways out and the only way that
people as a whole are going to improve their
lives is basically by bringing changes to the
tax system and making the wealthy people pay
higher taxes okay but that said there are a
few things ordinary people can do and we're going
to talk about what you can do oh but before i get
into that i just wanted to quickly add you know
if you are lucky enough to have say £50,000
£100,000 that you can invest and that's
kind of the amount of money that you really
need to be able to make like really significantly
sums of money that are going to affect your life
um just be aware that there's people out there
that don't have that and a lot of people don't
have that um one of the pieces of advice i'm
going to give is that if you don't have property
you should probably try and get property just
please be aware that there's like a huge number
of people especially young people out there
for whom that's just not a possibility so
yeah have a bit of awareness that if you do
have money saved up even though things might be
difficult for you there are other people out there
that don't have money saved up and things are more
difficult for them when i talk about changing the
system to make it fair for everyone that's going
to benefit you but it's also going to benefit
those people who have less and you know i'm super
aware of the people out there might be watching
that don't have that kind of money as well um
so what you can do really is super different
depending on where you are you know i'm not
going to patronize people who are struggling to
get by every day by telling them that there's
much they can do the truth is those people are
already doing everything they can right if you're
struggling to pay the bills you just got to keep
struggling like you're not going to make money
from investing and um if you've only got a few
thousand pounds that you desperately need please
don't be dragged into get rich quick schemes
you might see on the internet like bitcoin like
big bubbles in certain stocks like gamestop
or like tesla um you might have seen people
make money for them of course it's possible
but the truth is if you don't have a lot
of money to risk you shouldn't be getting
involved because those things can drop 80%
90% we've seen happen in the past and you could
lose everything you put in um yeah so if if you're
struggling to get by the main thing you need to do
is encourage people to support greater taxation of
the rich because that is the only way that's going
to really help the poorest people in our society
if you're lucky enough to have saved up a
bit more money 20 30 40 50 £100 000
i would say your first priority should always be
to get um property and this goes back to things
i've been talking a lot about in my videos right
so i've mentioned in my other videos about covid
that there's been a huge amount of money
printing that's going to devalue money
devaluation of money is kind of
a complicated concept right because
if you devalue money you know we normally think
of the price of whatever devalued things going
down but what is the price of money right
youknow the price of money can't go down
£1 is £1 but if money itself devalues what we
will see is the price of everything else going up
and uh in particular because the people who are
benefiting from covid are largely richer people who
tend to buy assets i expect to see the price of
assets like property like stocks and shares like
gold go up very quickly whereas wages probably
won't go up obviously that's not good news for
most ordinary people but it's also not good news
for people who have their savings in cash so how
do you avoid that? the main thing i would say is
really avoid keeping large amounts of savings in
cash um i know that we're conditioned to think
that keeping your money in cash is the safest
thing to do but when you're in a climate like
we're in now where prices of assets are going up
very quickly including property if you're sitting
on £50,000 in cash and the house price
doubles which unfortunately could do especially
here in london or even other parts of the country
that is really not a good situation for
you right so i would really encourage
if at all possible as soon as possible get
yourself some property because that gives you
the security that you can um that might involve
trying to get together as a family borrow money
from your parents it's important for people from
poor backgrounds to realize the reason why young
people get property is almost always because their
parents give them money and um this is the thing i
want to let people know because i know that people
from my sort of background poorer backgrounds
they see other people buying property and they
don't understand how it's possible because it's
almost impossible if you're in london even if
you're on like a higher salary like 40 50 £60,000
it's impossible to save up that deposit
it takes years and years and years and years
but people from richer families are
getting that money from their parents so
you know it's an unfair system but if you're from
a poor family the most important thing is to keep
hold of property that you have and to try and
get property for younger people that's going to
be the real challenge going forward especially
with property prices increasing as quickly as
they are now i know that's not super positive
advice for a lot of people to hear because
a lot of people they simply can't buy property
and you know this is why i do the work that i do
because you know i predicted a year ago that
property prices were going to go up despite
the worst economic crash in you know about 100
years that's insane but it's happened all right
we've had the worst economic crashing injuries and
probably prices have gone up that's because of the
way that governments have dealt with the crisis
which is to print money give it to rich people
the people that get hurt from that are poor
families don't have property but also ordinary
families i want to send the message out to
ordinary families that own property that might
think they're winning when house prices go up um
so the older members of those families that own
the houses they might think they're making money
when house prices go up but they need to realize
the only way to make that money is to sell
their house and if you sell your house
then your kids won't have houses and if house
prices double then your kids won't be able to
get houses with their own money so the
end result of this massive increase in
house prices is basically more and more ordinary
families going to lose their houses over the long
run so i would like to have a message for older
people that own property that might be excited
when house prices go up is think about how this
is going to affect your kids and your grandkids
the end result is basically going to be that most
people in this country will not own property in
20 30 40 years time and the amount of people
who own property going to go is going to become
less and less and less and less and less um and
that's going to make life worse for most people
um so look i see it in the families around me
right my friends who are from richer backgrounds
their parents give them a hundred grand they
re-mortgage the house give them a hundred
grand and the kids buy property but my friends
are often poor backgrounds i've got friends who
are from single parent families their mums have to
sell the house to get by and the kids get nothing
so what we are seeing now with this
massive increase in house prices
don't get excited about it because what it is
what is causing is a divergence basically where
if you've got 10 properties of course that's
great you've probably got a stock portfolio
as well that's gone up 10 times but if you
have no property your family's in big trouble
i don't i don't bring me no joy to
say that but if you have one property
probably also your kids and your grandkids will
become unable to own property in the future so
really if we want to stop that as a group we have
to do something about inequality and that's why i
said we have to tax the super rich it's the only
way to do it but as an individual like i said
i get asked what can do with your money the main
thing is protect your property and if you can buy
property if you're young if you can buy property
and if you're older help your kids buy property um
yeah you know that's not a positive message but
it's not a positive time if we don't fix the
economic system um but yeah if you are unable
to buy property now which i understand like a
lot of young people are um and you're worried
about the deposit you've saved up being devalued
there are sensible things you can do um don't
keep it all in cash invest in stocks and shares
invest in gold i've got a lot of money invested in
gold also have some invested in stocks and shares
um stocks tend to do well if the economy is good
so if you're an economic optimist you might want
to buy more stocks gold tend to do better when
the economy is bad so if you're an economic
pessimist you might want to buy more gold i've
got more gold if you buy a mixture of both then
you will probably be a bit more
secure whichever way it goes um
the best way to do that for an ordinary person to
open a stocks and shares ISA that's if you're here
in the UK um you can put £20,000 into thata year
you can just buy normal gold funds or global
stock tracker funds i recommend buying tracker
funds that buy a basket of stocks rather than
individual stocks because they're less risky um
you can only put £20,000 a year into an
ISA but if you have more you can just get what's
called a general investment account there's plenty
of providers online um i use free trade i use
hargreaves & landsdown but there's plenty
of providers that will give you ISAs that's
independent savings accounts uh they have
some tax advantages and if you have more money
general investment accounts GIAs um but yeah if
you have money saved up you're worried about being
devalued buy stocks buy gold don't leave it incash
um obviously keep some cash um and i have to
add to that like whenever i give advice like this
every single time you buy an asset gold stocks
anything there's risk involved um i think they're
going to go up in general because cash is being
devalued but that's no guarantee um be prepared
when you put the money in the value fluctuates day
to day could go up it could go down i think you're
more secure holding stocks in gold over the long
term than cash but um yeah there's no guarantee
when you buy things there's risk involved um
yeah what have you got any questions on that
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true